Whereas Koreans eat rice almost every day,...
...many people in other parts of the world eat potatoes as their staple food.
Peru is also one of the countries where potatoes are an important part of the local diet.
You might be surprised to hear that there are over 400 different types of potatoes in Peru.
Isn't it amazing?
They are served with everything and are cooked in many different and imaginative ways.
A trip to Peru will give you the most unique gastronomic experience of your life.
One more thing! If you want to taste the food...
...that Incan royalty enjoyed a long time ago, go to Lima in Peru.
The restaurant called Astrid y Gaston serves cuy, which is fried guinea pig.
Incan royalty once ate this dish as well as ensalada pallares, which is a spicy bean salad.
Why don't you go and try eating like Incan Royalty?